All right. So, what is the complaint and
the problem that we have with Netanyahu
Netanyahu and his agenda?
They want to control
what we say, how we say it, and they
want a green light to annex Palestinians
and to pretty much bring about the
greater Israel because Netanyahu is
deceived. He thinks that the land is
still his because he's still under the
old covenant mentality. You with me
there?
My point is, Yep. Exactly.
Netanyahu because he doesn't have Jesus
Christ, he doesn't believe in the
Messiah who has come, Jesus Christ, he
still thinks he's under the Mosaic
covenant.
He still thinks that covenant hasn't
been revoked. He still thinks that
covenant gives him the right to take
over
all the land that was given to his
ancestors
because the land that was given Israel
goes all the way to the border of Egypt,
right? And
the Nile River, right? That's that area.
He wants it all because he still thinks
that the covenant that God made with his
people through Moses, which included the
land, is binding because he has rejected
his Messiah, God and Savior and judge,
the Lord Jesus Christ.
And that's why he's going to keep
justifying that we are the ancient
people. It's our land. We own it.
It's our God-given right. No. When you
rejected Jesus, God rejected your
covenant.
You understand? And he's what is he? A
European, Ashkanazi Jew, and he thinks
he has more right to that land. All
right. Well, cuz this is the mentality.
He thinks he's under the old covenant.
Now, why am I mentioning this? I don't
want to get into this. Not trying to be
political, but guess what they're doing
right now as we speak? Netanyahu
and the powers that be are now in a deal
to buy Tik Tok. They want to now control
the narrative and social media and they
want to work with Ellen Musk to now
censor any criticism of Israel. They're
working to take over the social media
outlets.
They're right now in a deal to buy Tik
Tok.
See what they're doing? They want to
take over the media and they want to
demonize and censor anyone that doesn't
agree with their agenda.
Let me show you. Ready?
And you know what he calls people like
Tucker Carlson?
You know what he calls people like
Tucker Carlson? The woke not right.
Reich. Rei. Here it is. This was sent to
me and I just saw TYT commenting on it.
Evangelicals are the reason that is
>> from all my research evangelicals are
the reason that Israel has been
supported in public sphere outside of
just Jews. So with Charlie's
assassination and with the kind of
trajectory that we see with like Candace
Owens and Tucker Carlson, I guess I'm
curious about what's another game plan
if we lose evangelical.
>> Do you hear it? You Christian Zionist,
you're hearing it from Israelis.
They depend on you evangelicals
and they're afraid Christian Zionists
are going to turn against Netanyahu.
What is our next plan if we lose them?
Are you hearing it?
>> Support for the state of Israel. What's
our backup plan to be strong like
outside the diaspora?
>> Christian influencers.
>> Okay. He said we talked about the woke
right and he said I call it the woke
reich.
>> That's a brilliant
>> the woke right.
>> You know what he just called you right?
He called you if you dissent with his
indiscriminate bombing. And by the way
the UN now is calling it a genocide.
They're using the term and there are
even Jews
who are not anti-Jewish but anti-
Netanya saying this is a genocide.
you're doing to them what we said never
again to us. And he just used the
language of Nazism to call those like
Tucker Carlson Nazis
>> because these people, you know, they're
not any different from the woke the
left. I mean, they're they're insane.
They're
>> they're insane,
>> but they're actually meeting on some of
the things. And what we have to do is we
have to secure that part of our the base
of our support in the United States that
is being challenged systematically. A
lot of this is done with money. Money of
NOS's. You mean like Apac money pumping
millions in the pockets of politicians
like we send over $300 billion annually
to you.
And then at one time you were actually
financing kamas to use kamas as a
scapegoat so you can stay in power and
do what you did. That money
that money, huh? And you're talking
about money.
And this guy's beams are killing me.
>> Vast money of governments. Bastard.
Okay. We have to fight back. How do we
fight back? How do we fight
>> our influencers? I think you should also
talk to them if you have a chance to
that that community. They're very
important.
>> And secondly, we're going to have to use
the tools of battle.
>> You know, the the weapons change over
time.
>> You can't fight today with swords. That
doesn't work very well.
>> And you can't fight with the fight with
cavalry. That doesn't work very well.
And you have these new things, you know,
like drones, things like that. I won't
get into that. Oh, you see what he said?
Do you guys hear what he just said?
Threatening to send drones people, but I
won't get into that.
Did you hear it
from the bastard's mouth? I mean, the
horse's mouth. I mean, the demon's
mouth. Drones. But I won't get into
that.
What do you do with drones, buddy?
What do you do with drones?
We have to fight with the weapons that
apply to the battlefields in which we're
engaged. And the most important ones are
social media.
>> Social media. Look.
>> And the most important purchase that is
going on right now is
>> what?
>> Class followers.
>> Tik Tok.
>> Tik Tok. Number one. Number one.
>> And I hope it goes through because it's
uh it can be consequential.
>> The other one. What's the other one
that's most important? X
>> Twitter says
>> very good.
>> They're trying to get Ellen,
>> you know. So, we have to talk to Elon.
He's not an enemy. He's a friend. We
should talk to him. Now, if we can get
those two things, we get a lot. And I
could go on on other things, but that's
not the point right now. We have to
fight the fight, okay? To take give
direction to the Jewish people and give
direction to our non-Jewish friends or
those who could be our Jewish friends.
Are we going to succeed with everyone?
No. Will there be a strong counterpart?
Yes.
>> Evangel
and they're banking on evangelical
support. They're afraid to lose it. Here
it is. So guys, as we speak, not only
they're trying to pass legislation that
if you speak against what Israel is
doing, then you can have even your
citizenship revoked, right? You can be
prisoned. You can have your accounts
frozen, deleted,
deported. Now they're trying to buy Tik
Tok.
You're telling me this is not censorship
at its finest?
You're telling me we're not the United
States of Israel? Guys,
do you see why Nick Fentes said what he
said? Because you got to take things in
context. He's saying they have the
power, they have the influencers, they
have the military prowess to bring about
their agenda.
They want to now buy Tik Tok.
Is that a rising? Who would think we
would live at a time where now it's
going to be 2 years we're seeing the
children infants elderly in the name of
well because they harbor kamas
not only that but the starvation of
people the of churches
Christians as well the deliberate
of journalists and aid workers finding
doctors and aid workers would their
heads because They're trying to bring
aid to the Palestinians. Who would think
we'd live in a time like this? And we're
seeing
that they're trying to justify it,
meaning America and Israel.
So there you go, guys.
There you go. They're trying to now buy
social media.
And our buddy, apostate prophet, a
Zionist said, "I met him. I like him.
It's nothing personal. Dude, your
Zionism sucks. It's it's sickening,
right? Trying to now go after Nick
Fuentes and David is just there
following him, you know, like a deer
with his caught in in the headlights.
Whatever a positive prop and you wonder
why I speak out against them.
So there you go guys. There you go. Now
we're going to open up to the topic.
Just wanted to let you know they're now
trying to buy certain social media
platforms, outlets to control the
narrative. And if it goes through, Tik
Tok goes through. In fact, I think
when I was watching TYT, they said that
was it Tik Tok hired
an IDF was it? Or was it I don't know.
Someone they hired who is gung-ho Israel
and flights for Israel was an IDF
as part of Tik Tok. And you think he's
not going to have something to say about
blocking or censoring or silencing
voices that don't agree?